ya está conmigo en el estudio listo juan
hubo un revés en la decisión del comité
paralímpico internacional de la
participación de los atletas rusos y de
los rusos en los juegos paralímpicos de
beijing que comienzan mañana raúl si
esto es algo a lo que no estamos
habituados y mucho menos desde el
olimpismo ayer les contábamos aquí que
el comité paralímpico internacional
había permitido a rusia belarús
participar con restricciones en esos
juegos de beijing que se inauguran ya
mañana viernes pues en un plazo inferior
a 24 horas el mismo comité paralímpico
internacional dio marcha atrás a esta
decisión porque su presidente andrew
parsons asegura que en las últimas horas
ha recibido el llamado de varios países
miembros quienes le han advertido que
permitir la presencia de atletas rusos y
bien los rusos habría tendría
consecuencias graves a qué se refiere
por ejemplo a un escenario en el que
haya deportistas que se niegan a
competir con rivales de rusia o de
belarús por eso el comité va más allá
respecto a las medidas de ayer que
permitían la competencia de esas
naciones pero bajo bandera neutral y sin
exhibirse en el medallero escuchamos al
presidente
el bienestar de los atletas es y siempre
será una importante preocupación para
nosotros como resultado de la decisión
de hoy hay 83 para atletas directamente
impactados por esta decisión sin embargo
si el comité paralímpico de rusia y el
comité paralímpico de la ruth permanecen
aquí en beijing puede que hayan acciones
que se retiren es probable que no
tengamos un juego viable o traje pero si
esto ocurriera el impacto tendría un
mayor alcance espero y rezo para que
podamos volver a una situación en la que
las discusiones y la atención estén
totalmente en el poder del deporte para
transformar la vida de las personas con
discapacidades y en lo mejor para la
humanidad
juani en todo este contexto le
preguntaron también al presidente del
comité olímpico internacional sobre
hasta cuándo van a ir estas acciones que
dijo en este caso hablamos de tomás va
que quede claro que ni en un escenario
de ese es el fuego de tregua considera
que haya condiciones para levantar las
actuales sean récord destrucciones
recordemos que es precisamente el coi el
que recomiendo a los deportes del mundo
excluir a rusia y belarús
hemos dejado esto abierto una larga
discusión en la comisión ejecutiva tengo
que admitirlo
y era muy difícil tanto implementar una
fecha límite como definir un evento que
pudiese llevar a mayores sanciones o que
pudiese llevar a levantar algunas de las
sanciones